faire le point dans l'entreprise ce que
ça veut dire dans le commerce de détail
dans les usines secteur manufacturier
véronique prouve d'être pdg de
manufacturiers et exportateurs du québec
et marc fortin président du conseil
canadien du commerce de détail pour le
québec
à vous de bonsoir bonsoir sa première
réaction peut-être monsieur fortin là
sur la mesure de soutien aux
travailleurs autonomes notamment et aux
travailleurs qui n'ont pas accès à
l'assurance emploi au québec
définitivement pour nous c'est important
parce que on veut vraiment que nos
employés puissent avoir un support
financier quelconque parce qu'il va
falloir évidemment les récupérer aussi
après donc il faut que les gens puissent
être capables de survivre dans certains
cas il ya certains détaillants qui vont
pouvoir les supporter y en a d'autres
qui n'ont pas le moyen de supporter mais
il faut que tout le monde vienne
ensemble pour qu on peut s'entraider il
supporter tous les gens qui en ont
besoin et donc s'il faut les soutenir
c'est parce que beaucoup vont perdre
leur emploi ont président ne fais que
temporairement
c'est quand la situation dans le monde
du détail présentement c'est très dur
parce que évidemment l'achalandage
attend commencé à réduire est réduit
depuis trois semaines déjà
et puis les plus petits sauf beaucoup
plus que les plus gros qui ont les reins
plus solides mais elle est petit on
reçoit beaucoup d'appels qui nous disent
écoute vous nous aider on sera plus
capable payer la banque bientôt on sait
pas qui va payer nos factures
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir rester ouvert et ne
pas faire faillite
puis des moyennes entreprises aussi vous
parler d'un arrêt complet des ventes
dans beaucoup de cas évidemment le
commerce de détail au niveau de
l'alimentation de la pharmacie c'est un
autre domaine on en parlera tout à
l'heure mais au niveau du vêtement de la
mode et toutes autres industries
confondues où ça en route en les
coiffeuses que les les gens qui font des
fleuristes peu importe ces gens là on
arrache beaucoup et du côté des
manufacturiers madame prouesse que vous
recevez des appels des appels inquiets
bien sûr beaucoup de préoccupations
beaucoup d'inquiétude alors on ressent
l'effet du coc u19 depuis plusieurs
semaines déjà
notamment au niveau des chaînes
d'approvisionnement alors on a des
entreprises dont les fournisseurs
étaient fermés en chine mais
n'était fermée dont qui arrivait pas
accès à avoir leurs matières premières
leur fourniture leurs produits finis
s'allègent dans des délais bien sûr mais
également des coûts additionnels
mais depuis quelques jours la seule
préoccupation qui est différente
alors les entreprises mettent en place
leur plan de contingence évalue qui peut
faire du télétravail
j'ai plusieurs membres dont le personnel
de bureau travaille à la maison
mais bien sûr ce n'est pas possible au
niveau du personnel du sinn alors on
évalue qui est capable de rentrer
travailler les écoles les garderies sont
fermés salle ajoute une certaine
complexité alors vraiment les plans de
contingence à mettre à place on évalue
différentes situations et on suit la
situation très près dans la mesure où il
pourrait y avoir une baisse de la
demande ou dans le cas où les employés
ne pourraient pas venir travailler
mais c'est à dire que des trades et des
employés qui n'iront pas travailler on
aura des milliers d d d d peut-être des
centaines de milliers même des
consommateurs qui ne seront pas au
rendez-vous dans les prochaines semaines
ne seront pas donc au rendez vous est ce
que vous craignez des des failles et des
défauts de paiement est ce qu on est
dans une grande urgence
c'est clair qu'on est dans une grande
urgence et on suit la situation de très
près et c'est pourquoi on attend avec
beaucoup d'impatience les mesures qui
seront annoncées les mesures économiques
au niveau du gouvernement provincial et
je crois à la ronce attend des mesures
très fortes
soyons clairs la dernière en soyons très
clairs on ne veut pas seulement des
prêts et si ce qu'on s'attend à voir au
niveau provincial fédéral on veut de
l'aide directe on à son dénouement mais
ce dont ils ont besoin c'est des
liquidités donc des subventions de
l'allégement fiscal des moratoires des
paiements sur sur les paiements
hypothécaires sur les paiements au
niveau des banques
alors c'est une situation exceptionnelle
qui demandent des mesures
exceptionnelles et on s'attend d'un
leadership très fort la part des deux
paliers de gouvernement pour supporter
l'industrie et s'assurer qu'au terme de
cette crise parce qu'il y aura une
relance que les entreprises seront en
bonne posture pour reprendre le cours de
leur chose
et du côté des détaillants m'a écouté
les mêmes mesures s'imposent côté des
détaillants on s'attend à voir des
mesures solides ce qui a été annoncé
aujourd'hui déjà est un très bon début
ce sont des mesures nous avions demandé
au gouvernement provincial et au
gouvernement fédéral
on s'attend à avoir des allègements
fiscaux
dans les prochaines dans les prochaines
annonces parce qu'évidemment il faut
arriver à nos frais et rester ouvert et
garder les entreprises en allant quand
cette histoire quelques vite va être
fini va falloir qu'on soit là pour
pouvoir les aider encore là pour
reprendre à bâle
quel est l'impact sur les petits
détaillants indépendants et les
détaillants de centres commerciaux qui
ont beaucoup réduit leurs heures
d'ouverture
oui puis les heures d'ouverture ont été
réduites par les propriétaires des
centres d'achat et les marchands ont
suivi évidemment parce que ça demande un
certain coup guère rester ouvert qu'il
n'y ait pas de vente pas de trafic ça tu
peux pas vraiment souvenirs à la demande
donc ces petits marchands là comme je le
disais nous appelle beaucoup en ce
moment parce qu'ils vont être en défaut
de paiement avec les banques qui seront
pas capables de payer leurs différends
lors différents frais bientôt dans la
prochaine semaine je vous dirais même ça
va être quelque chose qu'on va voir de
façon ardue et pour les consommateurs il
ya une forme de freiner ville depuis
quelques jours sa séquelle mais
peut-être aujourd'hui est ce que les
consommateurs peuvent créer des pénuries
de certains produits
tout à fait on l'a vu jeudi passé
vendredi passé samedi ça commence à se
calmer on a fait beaucoup d'appels au
calme parce que les entrepôts ont des
produits les fournisseurs produisent en
alimentation nous sommes des services
essentiels
donc les produits sont là maintenant ce
que les consommateurs ont fait ce qu'ils
ont vidé les tablettes
et puis c'était une demande en trois
heures qui aurait dû souvent dans quatre
jours donc maintenant ce qu'on doit
faire c'est ramener les produits dans
les magasins
ça va se stabiliser d'ici jeudi ou
vendredi et normalement tout est dans
l'ordre ce qu'on essaie on se calme pas
besoin de six mois de papier toilette
tout le monde va y
on a vu des commerçants qui augmentent
les prix démesurément pour les lingettes
désinfectantes les masques le purell
est-ce qu'ils ont droit de faire ça m'a
écouté on l'entend d'une aussi on l'a
vue puis on a discuté avec les bureaux
cher et pour les non membres
puis c'est vraiment déplorable nos
bureaux chefs nous ont dit vous pouvez
même le mentionner qu'on a envoyé des
communications assez indépendant là pour
leur dire de ne pas faire ça mais ils ne
peuvent pas les obliger à ne pas faire
ça donc c'est vraiment le propriétaire
pharmacien ou le propriétaire du magasin
qui a décidé de faire quelque chose
comme ça qui est vraiment d
lara madame poulin derniers mois en
terminant mais écoutez on suit la
situation de très près on est bien sûr
préoccupé on reste en communication avec
nos membres pour voir comment la
situation évolue et on les encourage
meilleur à respecter le mot d'ordre
gouvernement provincial vernement
fédéral niveau la santé sécurité
merci beaucoup véronique true may fortin
merci bien merci